So your boy's been up to anything interesting recently.
I mean, we're currently back in lockdown, always.
So we haven't really been able to do much really Japanese covers pretty useless.
I mean, yeah. But.
See statement restaurant, please close at eight.
So you can still travel and do whatever you want. But you know.
It's not an enforced lockdown in Japan. It's always a suggestion.
It's a suggestion in Japan. People listen. Yeah, no, it's crazy.
I think like, uh, where was it? It was like,
it was because usually after we finished recording a podcast,
we'd go and have dinner and stuff like that. And I think we were at, uh,
like one of the restaurants nearby and they were playing like news footage and
the Shinjuku. Yes. There was a shot of [inaudible] station,
zero people in front of it, which is like crazy because she a station,
if you guys don't know is like literally the most busy station I think.
In the world. Isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. It is. Yeah.
It is at least in Japan, most of the world. I think that doesn't surprise me.
Shinjuku station. I die a little inside. Whenever someone,
whenever a friend comes to Japan, I asked where to me and they say, [inaudible].
Okay. Meeting at Shinjuku station is impossible, but like navigating it.
Isn't so bad. Yeah.
Oh, I hate nothing is worse than navigator. Oh,
what are you on? Because when you try and get to like the other ones.
Like the subway lines, you'd like, for some reason.
She literally has like 30 exits has maybe like 10,
like depending on which exit you come out of sh sh Shinjuku,
like it tells you to go on the other side of the station and you would think
walking in a straight line would work. No,
you can't walk in a straight line in Shinjuku because you've got to pass
depending on where you're on the station.
You've got to pass through like 10 different [inaudible] station. I always,
if someone's just like meet at this gate that I don't know where the it is,
then I'll just go out of the regular gate and I can at least walk around the
station. But if you try and do that with Shinjuku station, you're.
If you ever come to your pan and you're going to meet anyone here and you're
staying and you're staying there,
Shinjuku never say you're going to meet at Shinjuku station. It is a lie.
Okay.
It's saying you're going to meet at Shinjuku station is like saying you're going
to meet somewhere in like times square or something.
It's a massive area and station doesn't do it.
It's not even that it's like saying like, I'll meet you in New York. It's like,
all right, cool.
Like a place outside of the station and then send them the Google.
Yeah. But you could do that with any other station.
It'd be way easier to get out of it. Cause I, I remember I, uh,
I met Jeff here mother's basement at Shinjuku station.
And as soon as he said it, I was like, Oh, here we go. God, I got to find,
it's basically finding where's Wally with your mates. And you know, with Jeff,
is it shouldn't be hard cause he's massive. Right. And he says, um, he,
I asked him where he is and he goes, Oh, I'm uh, near this place. I think it's,
it looks like there's a big camera nearby. I'm like, cool. It's like,
cool. So I go to like the nearest big camera in.
So big camera is like this huge department store. Um, that is just like,
it's like electronic store basically. Um,
so I go to the UW West Shinjuku B camera,
and then I send him the message and I'm just like, okay, I'm outside big camera.
And he goes, I don't see you and I'm go buck.
It was that at that point I knew ticks off a one. I up. And I, and I,
and I tell him just to send me the Google map coordinates and he's on the other
side of the station is that Shinjuku.
You're West on Google maps. It's so much easier.
Also you can just literally meet at like one station.
Cause some of the stations lie with how to get places and like [inaudible] as
well has like a East West exit or so.
Not dude Shinjuku is like has like seven West.
It has an East West exit. Yeah. That doesn't,
it doesn't even like who doesn't even have an East West exit.
I think Shinjuku has like an East West exit and a new East West exit.
That's how many exits their own Shinjuku that they've literally run out of
directions to name the exits.
I missed the train stations in Wales where it's just a platform. What was it?
That was the whole station, maybe a vending machine. If you're lucky.
Honestly like what I usually do. Well,
I've done this with a few people and it's actually proven to be effective is
that instead of meeting in Shinjuku,
you meet one station down on the amount of which is Yogi. Because walking,
because walking to your Yogi,
like from your yoga to Shinjuku is the exact same time that it will take to
actually get out of Shinjuku station is because walking from one side of the
station to another, depending on where you are could take up to 15 to 20.
Exactly. Whereas like Yogi only has two exits,
very straightforward Nobre passions. What do you mean?
I'm doing what you love to do best? Which is midmaxing myself. Okay.
Well what is the optimal strategy? Right? Google has this thing now.
Where it tells you which cart to get on.
So it tells you which train car to get on for the smoothest and quickest exit
and 95% of the time. It's spot on. Just do that.
I see a trick question though. There is no smooth exit or Shinjuku. There is,
there is never.
I have legit. Like I always have to Goshen. Juki right.
And obviously I'm always to do that because I need to,
and I listened to what Google, my God, Google tells me, you know,
every time and it bang on, it's like go this exit globe,
the first set of stairs you see every single time it's basically right.
You think someone who just come to came to Japan ball,
like which direction of Shinjuku and which ex there are,
I don't even know where to exit. I get out of.
I mean, it works for me. I just listened to what the PC,
the PC master race tells me. If the computer's telling me to go somewhere.
I go where the computer center.
Okay. Carnival. The first time you come to Japan, don't do that.
I know how to do it. Find where you want to go. When you go to the station,
there'll be numbers on the floor. Just pick the number,
what the Google tells you to go on and then do it. Trust.
Shinjuku. You all get lost navigating the state. Yeah.
Don't don't trust the station signs. Cause there'll be like, Oh yeah,
if you're on the platform, be like the exit this way.
Well, you can go trust the station. That's all I've got. Because,
because when you go to Shinjuku and you follow Google maps, right?
Google maps says, take the West exit out of Shinjuku. And then you go,
you go to, you go out of your trailer, you go see the signs.
And there is literally every exit. But the exit that it says on Google,
they've made the mistake.
You're looking at the signs, right? The signs, the signs,
all they do is deceive you. They, they make you second guess. Right?
Don't listen to the silence full of.
Listen to what Google says a hundred percent, right? Because thing is right.
You'll be on the platform. Right?
And there'll be like eight sets of stairs that you can take.
That will be an hour. This is like this way.
This is the way to where you want to go.
And sometimes it's like the most unoptimized way to get out of like out of the
station or go to the line that you want to go. Right.
And there's a bunch of stairs. And sometimes it isn't clear which stairs to get.
It's a mess. Right? If Google tells you to get off at a cart,
go immediately to the nearest set of stairs that you see it.
I guarantee it'll work. And just go out the accident that you see closest.
It'll always work. Google knows. Don't listen to the signs there.
Try it, boys. You'll see. I dunno, man. I,
I think I'll just avoid getting off fishing. I just,
I just feel like not going through Shinjuku is just the optimal straps.
I'm just, I want to fly out of the country without an airport. It's like,
if I'm going to go to Japan, you're going to be going through Shinjuku.
But like I rather them.
Like somewhere far away from the actual station out of this place to
meet somewhere, anywhere near the station. Yeah. Because it's just extra.
It's just extra stress you're adding on to your commute.
Like if I do it for you, I don't know because it,
I have tried following the AI and Google maps. Isn't perfect. It's pretty good.
Is this, what is this why you hate? [inaudible] more because the AI.
Maps, I have no clue.
So that's why you hate, you can give it shot.
A mess of a station the way it's been laid out. Like shouldn't you cute?
I get it. It makes sense.
It doesn't say about EK Bukaro is that the science makes sense.
You can see the [inaudible] that when I follow her assigned to an exit,
it actually takes me to the eggs. Like,
because I like putting my trust in my own sense of direction. Right.
So if I'm in a place like Ethabuka though, I can trust that wherever I am,
I can find the right way out. I just follow the signs. I just follow the signs,
not the right way with Shinjuku. Um,
if you literally have to put your trust in an AI machine to tell
you the right direction, then it is just a poorly planned system.
It works though. I kept where I need to get to no problem. Well,
let's say that I wanted to people watching this, you'd never been to Japan.
Like what the is this problem.
In your don't listen to Kona,
meet anywhere outside of Shinji listen to the white guy in.
Would you trust the white guy?
Listen to me, the white guy, trust me. I find life hacks where they don't exist.